kids do not go to government educational
facilities to learn how to have sex or
at least that's not why they should be
there human reproduction should be
covered in Biology class at the
appropriate age but aside from that none
of this stuff should come up as I've
said before I don't even want abstinence
taught in the schools I'm not advocating
for an abstinence-only sex education
because now that would certainly be much
better it'd be a much better alternative
to the left to the left's preferred
strategy of instructing children on the
fine details of every sort of depraved
fetish but it still would not be ideal
because the most ideal scenario is that
the schools teach neither how to have
sex sex or how to not have it okay I
don't want any of the how-to these are
not appropriate or relevant
conversations for adults to be having
with with rooms full of children